come on y'all up a quick okay yo you  kind of cute for an agent the highway  races  I heard that let's go you're told to be  about twenty bucks  oh wow um that with the discount  yeah not tough like 50 bucks you even  been with a black girl before  oh you crazy oh you got a kilo sake  honey you'll make it you gonna get up  thank you guys alright now you have any  other tips come we don't know that no  it's not nothing  yeah so there's something called a  mattress disk  how do I knock off 70% off yo what the  [ __ ] oh yeah we just wrap this up with  you real quick that's real nice of you  thank you alright  appreciate it okay you can call me boo  you crazy night ladies okay y'all have a  good day  alright thank you come again y'all even  give you a number how many to back up  yeah you didn't give me you naughty  don't know over here some new shoes